my name is Alan Rosen I'm the
third-generation owner of Junior's
restaurant in downtown Brooklyn New York
Junior's cheesecake is the
quintessential New York cheesecake it's
been around for 67 years and the recipe
literally hasn't changed one ounce
my grandfather first opened a restaurant
here in Brooklyn New York
Election Day 1950 he said we're gonna be
a great restaurant New York we have that
great cheesecake and he literally went
around to different restaurants around
town that were known for serving good
cheesecake and he copied different
things that he liked the consistency of
this one the bottom of this one maybe
and he hit upon this formula and
developed that cheesecake recipe and all
the other good recipes that we have here
and the rest as they say is history
making cheesecake is truly like a labor
of love first you have to have the right
ingredients cream cheese fresh eggs
sugar heavy cream a touch of vanilla
then you have to blend it with a paddle
attachment the blending could take in a
big batch like we make it probably 45
minutes to an hour very slow speed
you're not into operating any air into
it so it's not fluffy and light it's
more of this edible ivory it's been
described as so you're blending those
ingredients you're then putting it into
a pan we put sponge cake on the bottom
which is different a little different
about our cheesecake you're gonna bake
it in a water bath what that means is
you're gonna surround each pan with
about this much water cheesecakes are
like a souffle so the cheesecake will
rise up it will bake to a golden-brown
without burning on the bottom you're
then gonna take it out of the oven and
not move it around at all let it settle
back into the pan you're gonna let it
cool overnight you then the next day you
gonna warm that pan just a little bit
just to get the cheesecake out of the
pan perfectly
you're gonna refrigerate it for a few
hours and then you're gonna serve it to
your friends and family every cheesecake
we have a junior starts with this basic
recipe we make crazy things too like red
velvet layer cake cheesecake Devils
which is the strawberry cheesecake
cherry blueberry
right now but I think if you're gonna
try Junior's cheesecake for the first
time you know playing slice is the way
to go out of a big cake because it's
more clean on the inside to experience
the gender in an article this is sort of
how you got to do it now what kind of
pop it's really hard to talk with
cheesecake either guys we've been here
for a really long time and as you can
see the neighborhood's changed people
have come and gone but because it's a
legitimate old-school Brooklyn you know
I think it resonates with people still
today they tell me stories how they got
engaged here they brought their kids
here after graduation it just means a
lot to us to be part of people's lives
in that way and we're just a restaurant
at the end of the day but it's something
that's been in this community for 67
years and so it's just always been part
of my blood it's part of my soul it's
what I love to do I get in the car and
come to work everywhere I'm excited so
I'm a very lucky guy
[Music]